if you're a film producer and who isn't
these days the highest honor you can
receive from our Academy is this the
Irving Thalberg award the Academy's
Board of Governors doesn't grant it
every year
it is named in honor of a visionary
young producer who changed the look of
motion pictures
Irving Thalberg knew about the pure joy
of movies he had an instinct for
audience pleasing entertainment and he
was keying a key judge of story and he
have very very shrewd eye for talent
from inception to completion he pursued
polished craftsmanship Irving Thalberg
established new watermarks for films in
the late 20s and 30s and now in the 80s
and 90s
another young hands-on producer has
changed the look and the sound of not
only his movies but everybody else's
movies the awesome list of audience
pleasing entertainment for which he is
responsible
earns the Irving G Thalberg moral award
for my valued colleague and great loyal
friend George Lucas
[Music]
George Lucas
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd like to thank the Academy members
and the Board of Governors for this
tremendous honor not only for myself but
for the thousands of talented men and
women robots and aliens and others with
whom I've been lucky enough to share the
creative experience in the last few
years
movies are not made in isolation it's a
group activity and it's only because of
the work a very hard work of many actors
writers directors producers creative
technicians thousands of assistants of
all kinds in projectionists and I'm able
to stand here and accept this award I'm
very very grateful to them all I'd
especially like to thank a group of
devoted individuals who apart from my
parents have done the most to shape my
life my teachers from kindergarten
through college their struggle and it
was a struggle to help me learn to grow
and learn was not in vain and it is
greatly appreciated I've always tried to
be aware of what I say in my films
because all of us who make motion
pictures are teachers teachers with very
loud voices but we will never match the
power of the teacher who is able to
whisper in a student's here Thank You
Francis for being my mentor and finally
thanks to my current and most important
teachers my two daughters they have
taught me more and enriched my life
beyond anything imaginable after 20
years this award comes at what I hope is
the halfway point in my career and I
assure you that I will strive to you
worthy of all it signifies thank you
very very much
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you